let's look at a reaction between a weak
acid acetic acid
and a strong base sodium hydroxide
let's say we have 100 milliliters of a
2.0 molar solution
of aqueous acetic acid and that's mixed
with 100 milliliters of a 1.0
molar solution of aqueous sodium
hydroxide our goal is to find the ph of
the resulting solution at 25 degrees
celsius
when the weak acid reacts with the
strong base a neutralization reaction
occurs
so our first step is to figure out how
many moles of our weak acid are present
and also how many moles of our strong
base are present
let's start with the weak acid we're
going to use the molarity equation
molarity is equal to moles over liters
so for our weak acid the concentration
is 2.0 molar so we plug that in
and the volume is 100 milliliters which
is equal to 0.100 liters
solving for x we find that there are
0.20
moles of acetic acid for our strong base
the concentration is 1.0 molar
and the volume is 100 milliliters which
is 0.100 liters
so solving for x x is equal to 0.10
moles of naoh
and because naoh is a strong base it
dissociates 100 percent
so if there's 0.10 moles of naoh there's
also
0.10 moles of hydroxide ions o h minus
in solution the hydroxide anions will
react with acetic acid
so our next step is to look at the net
ionic equation
for this weak acid strong base reaction
in the net ionic equation acetic acid
reacts with hydroxide anions
to form the acetate anion and water
because this neutralization reaction
goes to completion we draw an arrow
going to the right
instead of an equilibrium arrow and
instead of an ice table where the e
stands for equilibrium we use an icf
table
where i is the initial amount of moles c
is the change in moles and
f is the final amount of moles we've
already calculated the initial amount of
moles of acetic acid to be .20
and the initial amount of moles of
hydroxide anions to be 0.10
if we assume the reaction hasn't
happened yet the initial amount of moles
of acetate would be
zero next we look at the coefficients in
our balanced net ionic equation
the mole ratio of hydroxide anions to
acetic acid is one to one
therefore if we have .10 moles of
hydroxide anions
that's going to react with 0.10 moles of
acetic acid
so for the change we can write minus
0.10
under hydroxide anions and also minus
0.10 under acetic acid
for the acetate anion there's a
coefficient of 1 and the balanced net
ionic equation
therefore if we're losing 0.10 moles for
r2 reactants
we're going to gain 0.10 moles
of the acetate anion so when the
reaction comes to completion for acetic
acid we started with 0.20 moles
and we lost 0.10 so we're going to have
0.10 moles of acetic acid left
over for hydroxide anions we start with
0.10 moles and we lost 0.10 moles
therefore when the reaction comes to
completion there'll be zero moles
of hydroxide anions and for the acetate
anion we start off with
zero and we gain to 0.10 therefore we
will have
0.10 moles of the acetate anion so in
this case we started with more of our
weak acid than we did of our strong base
and therefore we ended up with acid
being in excess
the next step is to calculate the
concentration of acetic acid in solution
so we ended up with 0.10 moles of acetic
acid so we plugged that into our
equation for molarity
and when we mixed our two solutions
together the 100 milliliters of our weak
acid with the 100 milliliters of our
strong base
the total volume of the solution is 200
milliliters
or 0.200 liters therefore
0.1 divided by 0.200 gives the
concentration of acetic acid of 0.50
molar
and for the acetate anion we also had
0.10 moles
the total volume is the same so it's the
same calculation as before
0.10 moles divided by 0.200 liters
gives the concentration of acetate
anions of 0.50 molar
remember our goal was to calculate the
ph of the resulting solution
so to calculate the ph we're going to
need the concentration of acetic acid
and the concentration of acetate anions
so we know we have some acetic acid in
solution and acetic acid reacts with
water to form the hydronium ion
h3o plus and the acetate anion ch3coo
minus
this reaction is a weak acid equilibrium
problem so we have an equilibrium arrow
and we're going to set up an ice table
for initial concentration
change in concentration and equilibrium
concentration
we just calculated the initial
concentration of acetic acid to be 0.50
molar
and if we pretend like the acetic acid
hasn't ionized yet
the initial concentration of hydronium
ions would be zero
and the initial concentration of acetate
anions from the ionization would be zero
however we just calculated that there is
a concentration of acetate anions
already in solution
and that concentration was 0.50 molar so
on the ice table i'm going to write down
here
0.50 for the acetate anion
next we think about some of the acetic
acid ionizing
and we don't know how much so we're
going to call that x so under the change
we're going to write minus
x the mole ratio of acetic acid to
hydronium ion is one to one
so if we write minus x under acetic acid
we need to write plus x
under the hydronium ion and for the
acetate anion there's also a coefficient
of
one so we're going to write plus x under
the acetate anion
therefore the equilibrium concentration
of acetic acid is 0.50
minus x and for hydronium ion
it would be 0 plus x or just x and for
the acetate anion it would be 0
plus 0.50 plus x or just
.50 plus x
notice that there are two sources of the
acetate anion
the 0.50 molar came from
the weak acid strong base neutralization
reaction that we previously discussed
the other source of the acetate anion
comes from
the ionization of acetic acid and that's
this
x here so 0.50 plus x indicates there
are
two sources for this common ion
therefore this is a common ion effect
problem the next step is to write the ka
expression for
acetic acid so we can get that from the
balanced equation the ka
value for acetic acid at 25 degrees
celsius is equal to
the concentration of hydronium ions
raised to the first power
times the concentration of acetate
anions raised to the first power
divided by the concentration of acetic
acid raised to the first power with
water being left out of our equilibrium
constant expression
next we plug in our equilibrium
concentrations from our ice table
for the hydronium ion it's x for the
acetate anion it's 0.50
plus x and for acetic acid it's 0.50
minus x here we have our equilibrium
concentrations plugged in
and also the ka value for acetic acid at
25 degrees celsius
next we need to solve for x and to make
the math easier we can
make an approximation with a relatively
low value for
ka for acetic acid acetic acid doesn't
ionize very much
therefore we know that x is going to be
a very small number
and if x is a very small number compared
to 0.50
0.50 plus x is approximately equal to
0.50
the same idea applies to 0.50 minus x if
x is a very small number compared to
0.50
0.50 minus x is approximately equal to
0.50
and with our approximations the 0.5
zeros would cancel out and give us x is
equal to 1.8 times 10 to the negative
fifth
from our ice table we know that x is
equal to the equilibrium
concentration of hydronium ions
therefore at equilibrium the
concentration of hydronium ions is equal
to 1.8 times 10 to the negative fifth
molar and because our goal was to find
the ph of the solution
ph is equal to the negative log of the
concentration of hydronium ions
so when we plug in that concentration we
get the ph is equal to negative log of
1.8 times 10 to the negative fifth which
is equal to
4.74 so if you
react a weak acid with a strong base and
the weak acid
is in excess the ph
of the solution will be less than seven
it will be acidic